foreign
[Music]
it's funny I know that you strategically
made your chair hire and and yet I don't
mind yeah I don't mind well you're also
shorter than that right well yeah but
yeah but not my torso right because it
height is in the legs although you have
a very long torso because I have also a
long legs no if your legs were
proportional if your body was in
proportion to your legs you'd be
that's no dude what are you talking
about I'm good proportion man no but I'm
saying from your legs or not my legs are
doing fine do you know I want you to
before we get into this yeah I'm really
excited about giving advice because I've
lived a life and a lot of people have
said I've lived a Champion's life right
people have said you live in Champions
life I hear that okay like Brian County
lives in Champions League yeah okay
um I want you to think people have said
that I want you to dress differently no
I so I can't I've actually tried to I
know me too no no I've tried to dress
differently but you look like the guy
who didn't make it in NASCAR but you
know what is that fair but here's what I
don't know if that's fair well you know
it's like it's like it's like he would
have done it he would he would have had
it but he got all caught up you know nah
dude listen no you look like the guy he
got caught up that's the problem I tried
it I heard he was amazing he had all the
talent he would have been a superstar
but he got caught up
with driving just out of [__] you know
to drugs and stuff yeah all that dude
you look like you did all the drugs and
all the booze you went through your face
and and now you're out of it but it's
too like it's too late you never drank
no no I never drank dude you know that
yeah you suffer probably from the guy I
don't you know what I've done mustard
turkey and no sun you know what dude
what I don't suffer
period right
we can agree okay
look yeah I am looking and you know what
I see what
careful okay because you see somebody
who's squared away and put together I'll
tell you what you see and I'm gonna say
this I'm glad we're doing this if you
and I are walking down the street
separately uh-huh
they're mugging the [__] out of you
right no because you don't look like
you're squared away you look like a
whole bunch of different moving Parts
everything about you is in shambles it's
unorganized that guy could have made it
in NASCAR but he didn't they're not
going to say that nobody's saying I look
like I could have made it in NASCAR but
I did it might also say he's been on a
boat for too long dude that's not true
why you look like you've been on a boat
like I'm disheveled I'm organized my
body's unorganized yeah you do I keep it
on a boat I'm not saying you're a
Castaway although you could be I'm
saying you just been on a boat for too
long tearing up in the dock you never
even got off the [__] off the boat
you stayed in the slip and you drank and
until you guys got to the next [__]
slip what's a slip
it's just it's where you put your boat
okay pay a slip fee dock like a docking
it you're the [__] steer that dude I
don't I I the point is this before you
talk about my [__] appearance if
you're walking down the street it's fine
if you're walking down the street yeah
I'm not getting Predators Predator see
like the wounded animal okay you gotta
you gotta you got a limp or something's
going on with your [__] because your
legs are not everything I don't have a
limp dude and my legs are [__] fine
size okay but they're skinny a little
bit but yes but there's this right
there's this you see me there's no
wasted space right there are no errant
Parts Brian you see someone who's
squared away your squared away yeah okay
and he's going to give you the what for
it and meet you halfway if there's a
problem don't step to them because he's
got eyes everywhere
and I'm [__] cat quick and I'll tell
you something else what I'm on the balls
of my feet that doesn't matter dude
listen until it comes down no yours
comes down mini your mini there I said
it your mini I've always wanted to tell
you that no I'm here your head's mini
your shoulders are mini
you're 70. dude you're and there's no
you are you are not 170. yes I am no
you're not and and you're five what nine
I'm fine for real bro be real you're 911
I'm in flip-flops right now get a tape
do we have a tape measure no I mean we
don't have a [__] tape measurement
and I'm taller than five eleven you're
not five eleven and yes I am too you got
one he's got one come over he's got one
[__] he's got one we measure the
height yeah
yeah dude I'm look at that look at how
square away I am look at my shoulders
three inches
go ahead and measure I'm in flip-flops
I'm in my toe holds
all right what's it say okay oh it says
511. there we go look how I look at five
eleven
's right here for me no it's not no it's
not no you are taller oh [__] oh
[__] I'm six I'm almost six three
okay hey dude hey you got shoes on
e-mini no you got shoes on but let me
just tell you something dude okay yeah
so you're going to probably where this
weekend you're probably going some dude
that's not I can hold down you're gonna
fall in her I can hold that for a half
hour you're you're you're so we can we
can agree
um that uh uh well we could agree that
I'm taller okay okay and you're mini
you're a mini not me so you're not mini
so what's mini then well dude that mini
is is what you what you would be if your
torso was in proportion to your legs I
already said it no that's not true my
torso is in proportion to my legs and
also dude if my legs were proportion to
my torso oopsy
yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't be an
athlete because nothing moves together
it wouldn't be an athlete because it
doesn't matter to be an athlete okay for
me I got The Gift of Gab I used it to my
[__] I used it to my advantage and
now your boy could talk the doors off
okay I could talk I could be in a room
and dude oh I'm in trouble I see all
these people closing in I could talk the
doors off this place and I'll tell you
about I'll tell you what these guys now
on my side yeah
lifting a finger a lot of people come to
me for wisdom and that's why I'm here
they don't do that and a lot of that's
because I've lived close to the Bone and
when I say when I say sticks to your
ribs now here's the thing it means
nothing so you do have the Gift of Gab
and you do talk well thank you and I
just convinced you of that because of my
gift yeah but my my Kung Fu no dude uh
Master used to always say
that a hollow tree
makes the loudest noise when you bang it
okay so one of the reasons that you
don't hear from me a lot I hear from you
a lot but when it when it comes down to
it so when there's no left turn or a
right turn you do you see me go from my
the balls of my feet to my heels yeah
now it's time for Daddy to dig down and
dig deep right it means nothing dude
when I when I root my my heels in the
American soil and I start and I start
playing for keeps yeah now you're not
gonna hear a [__] peep okay you're
just gonna hear pop pop pop so you are
gonna hear about something that's gonna
be my fists doing their work I do okay
you're a stupid [__] or or or using
open hand slapping not slapping hey it's
that redistributing the weight right
well it's my cheese it goes away chakra
and it goes into your heart your heart
stops and
now you die here's the good news there's
no good news if I die Okay no Okay I
revive you I know how to reply right
dude and that's a warning right I took
you to 80s and I brought you back all
right all right listen man no no no dude
no can we just [__] get to the
podcast dude let me just say this I
wanted to establish a couple things yeah
I I that's fine dude that's all you ever
establish you say you're close to the
Bone you've got your bootstraps on yeah
and whatever the [__] get the tattoos
out here you're squared away I'll get
more dude I'm gonna be so tattooed up
and you know why what because I'm
different now no and it's gonna and and
and you know what I you know what I do
have to do for real yeah if I get more
tattoos I said to the tattoo artist I
was like dude I actually I want to get
some more tattoos of what do I get I was
like maybe a snake maybe a diagram no I
know you did but I know exactly how you
got your tattoos you went to the tattoo
artist no and you held up a picture this
is not true you did you said I know
exactly what the how you got your
tattoos you said to the tattoo artist
you held him a picture
of a stripper in Portland and you said I
want to look exactly like this turning
me into a human doodle pack a male
stripper no a male stripper a gal
stripper you're saying
you're saying I could dance around but
if I had to dance around a pole if I had
to dance I could do it and I can I can
make women attracted to it you know how
women are like no we don't like that
[__] we're like I got to be manly yeah I
can actually take it to the next level
dance around a pole and the women go
like this oh come on okay no I don't
okay I guess I'm in I don't no I guess I
just I'm involved the one goes like this
I didn't ever really think I would be
involved with something like this but I
guess I'm involved you know what I'm
doing too what I got the towel and I'm
holding it and I'm doing the thing and
the crowd's over there and the woman's
here and I'm like this I'm like you
could you could if you want okay so
after after Channing Tatum comes out
this is I'm the MC at the mail street
but now ladies and gentlemen put it
together it's got the gift of God he's
got long straight very oily hair so be
careful and clean under your nails after
you run your fingers through his hair
shitty he's white he's long he's covered
in moles
dude someone Wheels me off just like
this oh god dude have you shaved or
anything no no it's it's really wiry
what but it's really wired but at least
you cleaned up right no no nope dude
open anus out everybody's like just yeah
oh God but the girls but the must the
haters do that but the girls are like
this I'm involved and I tell you what
too
um it's not they're not drunk and
blinded by your life yeah they are dude
but you're showing them your [__] is
at least are you aroused are you just
all heavy and lazy no no I'm not and
just hair yeah you know what my penis
looks like what someone on the subway
yeah dude
so it looks like the Living Dead it
looks like the Living Dead yeah if I put
a cup like a paper cup like you know
with the frayed edges next to my penis
yeah people will be like oh poor guy and
put money into it well you probably have
your guy your dick hole is stretched
just so so you can actually put small
coins in there
yeah that would be really gross yeah
that would be really gross and also and
also if if wind can go into it yeah yeah
and if you can make noise yeah but okay
so so I go to the tattoo artist and I'm
like hey I need more tattoos and he goes
yeah okay I'm a little worried and I was
like why oh am I getting too many too
fast and he goes absolutely not it's
totally cool yeah
what I'm worried about is
he says first of all what did he say
this yeah he says well he said this is
exactly what he said I said I want to
get more tattoos and he hit me right
away with this you're 40. I know I know
no no he didn't say that he said I'm
worried about your towel situation I
said what's this mean he said how many
big bags from I like Ikea size bags do
you have and I said what are you talking
about he says here's what I'm worried
about he was like does it gets real nice
to me he goes like this here's what I'm
worried about I'm just gonna be straight
for you like I know you have you know
obviously you can get the tattoos you
can you have the money and all that [__]
you have the space on your right even
though your shoulder's going for days we
have the space right yeah because we did
someone we're gonna do something on my
shoulders yeah he goes like this he goes
like this what I'm a little worried
about is you start getting more tattoos
you walk or stay walking in your car
yeah okay and all of a sudden a few
women are walking by yeah I'm worried
for their if if they because it gets
because they're because what they can do
is fall down and here's why I know why
why they fall down this because when
they see me with all and I'm yadded up
right and you see stuff peeking out
right but you see stuff peeking out
right and I've got clothes on and I've
got enough clothes on yeah you see stuff
peeking out right yeah yeah so you know
I got something under yeah okay which
signifies you you live only yes yeah and
I do and so if if a bunch of women see
that now all of a sudden they're in
Jeopardy for they can they can get they
can get abrasions they can get a bunch
of strawberries on there right by
Falling they can they can hurt their
back
because this I said he says he's worried
that they'll slip and I said because
they're what and he's they're dripping
on the floor
is that why
yeah
I asked him I said so what the [__] he
says that's why it's about your towel
situation
if you need more tattoos he looked at me
and said I'm gonna be very Frank with
you yeah
you need more towels yeah and I need to
bring and I said and I was like all
right I guess so yeah
I have a bunch of big Ikea bags that I
keep with me right
five or six and each of them have
12 towels in them but more yeah so
because it shows you have to pass them
out so that they can dab their vagins
gross yeah so they go like this
yeah
this is for you yeah and now if you go
to jail
yeah
say you know whatever you get you you
get put in jail for murder right because
you know you're hard yeah what gang are
you in in jail I uh
I start my own yeah you start your home
yeah I make everyone jealous of the get
of my cool new gang your cool new gang
is what what do you have to do to be in
your cool new gang no no honestly we we
uh there's not really there's no and you
can just be watering and [__] if you get
terrible you're gonna get traded for
cigarettes no I go like this you want to
[__] my ass
okay let's do it but I you don't [__] my
ass I [__] your dick
with my ass they go like this oh I'm not
all prepared for that here's what I
would do if you were in jail I would say
Chris go like this with your finger
now go like that okay now put that right
in my belt loop and stay close to me
dude first of all you don't have and
then and then I'm gonna trade you for
Contraband what why would I carry on
even back in a half hour because cell
block d
well we it's bored so listen dude how
much time it's okay go pull up my things
here pull up my things here all right so
we're gonna so we're gonna first what
we're gonna do is I I guess I'm on we
got more dates on sale okay so yeah I
know crazy right whoa and you can open
for me if you want to but I'm not
opening for you so Charlotte North
Carolina Knoxville look at all these
dates Little Rock Arkansas Nashville
keep it moving Calgary
Ottawa Edmonton Montreal Hamilton
Cleveland Detroit Orlando Fort Myers now
do it hey he keeps the seats warm right
because they show up he keeps them warm
but not too warm right because sometimes
they stand in the middle so sometimes
you stand in the middle dude you ever
got understanding ovation
middle
people are always like hey got a
standing ovation oh really yeah I
wouldn't ever get one in the mid I
wouldn't hear what you're saying in
Arizona before you you came in and and
and sabotaged my show yep me and my show
no my show I made it mine no yeah
no no no no listen listen I'm gonna be
in Portland oh The Helium Comedy Club I
keep it small I keep it tight I keep it
in right right right right because
that's because I keep it real because I
stick to my roots okay all right and
then I'll be at the fasani theater
in Port Charlotte Florida making places
up okay
yeah.com I went there oh you went there
okay
still on your website all right I know
I'm not good with that comedies are not
good at that dude yeah I know all right
dude all right just go to just go to
briancount.com a lot of dates if you
like to laugh yeah and uh I'm big I'm
Chris's biggest influence no you're not
dude one time I saw one time I saw uh uh
you know how they would do like comedy
shows around town and [__] like and they
would have flyers for them when we were
coming up to instead of one time one
time I saw a flyer and it said got no
money but still want still like to laugh
and it was like come on down free show
no I'm not even making a joke about your
thing but it was like got no money and
still liked to laugh and I was like oh I
almost wanted to quit got no money but
still like this flyer for what for like
something in Canoga Park like a [__]
you know what I mean yeah I I I get that
you do those shows no I don't don't
um all right so go to if you have a
question go to you know look at the
[__] uh
watch lifeline.com and then the new
merch is at lifelinemerch.com uh now
you're you're gonna give people advice
in the show yeah [__] yeah dude okay now
we save people's lives I understand but
you don't live a normal life so what are
you gonna I can get down and dirty with
people because same life no look at my
hands okay my hands have been my hands
have worked my hands bro you're Mini
now dude you know what I walk around
like I'm six two I'm six two uh six you
walk through two here in my heart okay I
got the Heart of a Lion all right dude I
do so uh they call me Lionheart you know
that they don't do that movie all right
so let's go to the first person here and
we're gonna and this is what we do and I
know you've seen every episode because
you love it your favorite podcast
oh by the way Matt couldn't be here
because he's sick that's why he can't be
here yeah he's got a weak Constitution
all right well don't say that about my
brother you put me you and Matt in an
elevator Jesus Christ dude you know what
you'd be doing pushing buttons
I would but until until
that's the Korean guy who comes on and
says uh he says
you have one minute to fight to the
death
and I would and 30 seconds later I'd be
going ding ding opening the door and I
have some scratches on me but you'd both
be dead right because I could kill both
you with my bare hands in an elevator I
don't even know that you need that much
room to move it doesn't matter dude you
don't know so right rumor no room
because I would take your brother and I
love your brother but if it came down to
squid games yeah yeah I would I would
break his neck I hate to do that and
then I'd take him by the ankles and I
would beat you to death and that sucks
to say out loud but that's how I would
win a fight you'd beat me to death with
my brother's ankles because no he's thin
I would pull one of his arms off
you can't you're not a [__] ape I'm
[__] stupid strong when it comes down
to competition dude you know what you
find a way to win you know what's going
to happen to you one day what you're
gonna be you're gonna I'm gonna see you
one day and it's gonna be soon dude and
and I'm gonna see one day I'm gonna be
like oh it finally happened you're
actually you're too old no yeah and it's
and it's no this is what this is what
age is like this is what age is like for
you
that's what it's doing no it's not that
is dude no it's not
no it's not yeah come on no age is going
like this I can't I can't find a way in
I don't know it's just it's something
different about him his dick is always
hard what well it just I'm vital I'm I'm
feral I have a Vitality um all right so
all right let's go to the first one here
and then we're gonna do it
oh look at that well that's your brother
yes it is what's up everybody uh
sorry I couldn't be there today uh
missed being there I wanted to be there
but I couldn't because
I got covered
and I didn't want to give everybody
covered so I'll be responsible he's not
coming home and um
Chris what's up man uh I haven't seen
you since the special
uh
uh which went off amazingly and uh I
miss you I love you sorry I can't be
there today love you too I heard you
have a guest host I heard you asked
somebody to fill in and uh I think you
said it was
uh
new friend Ryan uh Ryan Callum Brian
Callan you know so thank you Ryan for
filling in for me so disrespect you're
available
um you would be and you were so that's
great
um my I actually do have something I
wanted to see your guys advice about
them okay
um which is why I'm making this video in
the first place uh Chris it's mainly for
you but also Ryan you can chime Brian
you got some ideas as well uh the seat
that you're sitting in right now Ryan is
actually my seat as as you know as
everybody knows and
um I since now you're in it
um I'm a little I don't want to say
concerned or worried but I I'm trying to
figure out what the best way forward is
whether I just like clean it regular do
I power clean it do I bleach it do I
hire
the whole area that I'm sitting in that
you're sitting in now that I usually sit
in is clean and up just enough after you
kind of yeah
muck it up get in that whole area with
your own whatever stuff let's talk about
psoriasis
I don't wipe I would appreciate any any
of any and all advice on the subject
um
yeah all right love you Chris love you
everybody listening and uh thanks again
Ryan uh big shout out to Ryan Collins no
it's private account for me okay so he
said so he knows about psoriasis
you don't wipe your ass I don't believe
in wiping because I believe in being
natural that's disgusting all right yeah
I believe I air dry okay now listen what
um
we'll just get a new chair yeah get a
new chair because also I sell it on eBay
and make a fortune no dude right I make
a fortune if we sold Brian counts here
honestly how much you think we'd get for
it well it depends on if you want to
ovulate or not and if you want a child
what yeah what are you talking about my
son my scent actually causes women to
ovulate yeah that's a fact that's a fact
a nutritionist yes that see I got you
there because that's never would tell
you that okay well maybe I wouldn't know
the Qin but I know I only go to
nutritionist for everything for all my
advice including my financial advice I'm
so broke I know I know I invested in raw
milk
[__] man they told me I could turn into
yogurt and I did a terrible job I bought
like I bought pallets of raw milk that's
terrible I don't know people say that
you shouldn't take advice from Realtors
but you're taking advice from a
Nutrition Milk Futures they told me to
buy milk Futures because they said that
what is milk future you buy milk and you
just you you bet that the milk is gonna
go way up in value because
that cows are not as plentiful as the
media is making them see milk that's not
what the media is lying about the media
is lying about everything else in the
world but not that dude is lying about
everything else is going on the
government everything else is happening
with all the different movements but
it's not that that they're lying about
you should invest in milk because
everybody's gonna want milk and it's
going to be as short yeah
but they're not lying about that
at least at least at least I know that
fauci told the truth
about me too but they're not lying about
that
dude
that man this
man listen I have some advice for your
brother okay
um Matt
no
Danzig just texted me from the 80s he
wants his [__] earrings back stupid
Danzig watches
he's got a dang the earring but you know
what he's got a dangly cross but you
know what I'm gonna get hey get that
dangly cross from the 80s and give it
back to one of the singers from Wham
okay to the to not George Michael but
the other singer from Wham you know I'm
going to give that back to him when I
when you when you pass away and I'm not
whatever it is I'm not I'm not saying
it's going to be 2006 whenever you pass
away just had a checkup came back
Immortal okay you're not getting my
immortal all right you can still get hit
by bus so here's the deal
very very big I'm gonna put you on it
and just walk and drag you behind me no
yeah yeah you're like this no and get
tattoos on you you'll be dead you're
kidding I'm gonna get tattoos
dude I'm now I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
be turned into a Christ figure I
appreciate it I appreciate it but I'm
not gonna be turned into a Christ figure
I'm not I refuse that there's there's
only one Jesus and yes I give and yes I
am an example of of Grace Under Pressure
whatever in my opinion and yes and yes
yes yes
I'm a moral Warrior but you're not I'm
not gonna let you turn me into a Christ
figure obviously you're gonna die way
before me you already look older that's
not true when you say that I feel like I
lose I lose years I know you're a
creature of the night a creature of the
night speaking of creature of the night
I do sleep I do go to sleep late and I
wake up late and then and then
Christian's like why didn't you wake up
early so anyway let's go to the next one
so anyone knows she says when we wake up
and make eggs for the baby so anyway
let's go to the next one no no no no no
no no then I say hey baby you know maybe
Calvin should eat muffins maybe he
should eat eggs and she says why don't
you wake up early and do it then I feel
bad and we get another government so
anyways okay now here's what I do with
my baby here's what I do with my baby I
put some organic milk in there okay in
there so I make him a protein shake
listen to this because babies are
finicky so I take a banana I take
strawberries I take some oats I take
some some whole milk okay some organic
boring by listing a bunch of [__]
grocery items okay so let's move on from
that you said a bunch of grocery items
let's move on okay because I get it and
I put some spinach in there whoops oh
you got more boring how do you [__]
go from the most boring list to then say
try to teach you about nutrition all
right you can get your kid to eat have a
shake all right cool it's sweet and it's
delicious all right all right cool so
anyway so keep going so you can't feed
feed your kids sugar cubes that's not
the way to take are you how are you
feeling maybe I can help you he wakes up
sometimes we give him muffins because
it's like you know okay muffins but what
else do all right
what else do you do
what else just it's fine I'm not going
to judge you okay all right what else
are muffins okay muffins then he plays
on a pad for a while plays on a pad for
a while yeah okay what other nutrition
do you give hey all right um after that
maybe I don't know he'll maybe like see
the dessert I got last night from
Postmates and I'll be like on that and
I'll give them something that's a lot of
stuff like chocolate's good okay what
else did you give him then then maybe
I'll give him some turkey and mustard
and he mostly just eat some mustard so
he's living a mustard cake and yeah and
more cake he's smart so far though no
he's not gonna grow with mustard okay
dude my special is gonna cry it's about
your kid oh yeah yeah I know I know but
I did it and I was dialed in okay I know
the first one went great didn't need the
second one did the second one and I was
dialed in dude
listen it's different now it's different
dude he tells the story oh for [__]
sake he tells the story it's not just
about comedy anymore over [__] sake he
was forced on the leveling up oh he was
was he hey who'd you see last night I'll
give you a hint he was dialed in oh
he came out to fire oh [__] he's got his
story to tell them dude I know they're
teaching man tears my special on
YouTubes in school they are you don't
hear me [__] talking about that no
it's a chock full of metaphor Chuck full
of messages and You're gonna laugh so
hard don't have the family with you
because it's just got to be a personal
experience You're gonna laugh you're
gonna cry and you're gonna change and
that's the difference no and my next
specialist called You're Gonna Change no
that you can't because you because you
don't have a choice are you working new
no before we get am I working new
material yeah am I working new material
why didn't you say that and then I come
see you and then sometimes you're doing
[__] from Mad TV some days I decide I'm
gonna I'm gonna rehash some of the
oldies because people Classics give us
the hints and it gets so overwhelming I
go I'll give you one hit all right but
for the most part all right am I working
on something new
yeah this obnoxious I know but
Sasha Powell right
and you see him Burr yes
come see me
that's not a big deal not a big thing
you're saying you're putting yourself
you've seen you've seen you've seen
Bruce yes you seen prior yeah I know
them I've seen them you've seen Carl
I've seen him you've seen him okay
come see me so you're putting yourself
in it by by saying that you're not
directly saying it but you are putting
yourself saying anything
I'm not saying anything
what's that all right all right you can
hear what other people are saying don't
do that but I'll tell you what all right
what
and you're doing a great job
okay watch you're special yeah
I'm gonna call my Transcendence and then
watch man tears all right dude man tears
dude Russell Peters gave me that I'm not
good at naming I'm not good at branding
and I'm not good at merch I'm not good
at those things we know that because I'm
so deep in heart I'm so knee deep in art
yeah that I forget about the Commerce
I'm calling mine the American that went
up a hill but came down a mountain
is there a better title because that's a
really that doesn't really roll off I've
thought about it the American who went
up the hill and do you guys see that see
watch watch uh I watched that special
the American went up the hill and then
came down again do you guys watched that
a mountain he went up the American that
went up a hill but came down a mountain
the American I went up a hill and came
down to Mountain see I don't even know
what that means so much well you will if
you see the whole thing dude you know
why I got a story to tell Dude here's
the deal my shit's gonna [__] oh [__]
what my [__]
when is it dropping yeah I don't know
yet because I have to make sure that the
world is ready
the world is ready
why what do you mean so they're ready
they've seen man tears they've seen
complicated all right so look let's do
another [__] one here but anyway my
my mama called my gangbusters hey guys I
want to talk to you about something
called Next Evo all right uh when it
comes to Wellness okay Wellness is very
important a lot of people think it's
about nutrition and exercise and it is
but it's also about other things that
are at least equally as important like
physical mental and emotional health uh
so sleep Stress Management and uh
mindfulness are all important aspects of
Wellness uh doing your research before
you buy means making better informed
choices especially when it comes to
stress or Sleep Products like CBD a
study by an independent lab confirmed
some Brands contain up to 60 percent
less CBD than they claim on the label
all right but listen here with next Evo
Naturals you can trust you're getting
the best of the best as the most
clinically studied CBD brand on the
market that's this right here next Evo
it takes research to the next level
great to relieve stress
um great to pop and then get in bed and
have a great night's sleep that kind of
stuff wake up feeling you feel refreshed
and well rested vegan GMO free
gluten-free THC free capsules and
gummies delivered from 100 U.S grown
hemp upgrade your CBD go to nextevo.com
Lifeline to get 20 off your first order
of 40 or more that's 20 off forty
dollars or more at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash lifeline
here we go
this is a guy first of all shade that
much I have a question okay I need
advice on
stupid as [__] he's buckled in because
the correct way
to flip someone off
I used to do it like this
with the thumb out yeah like an L that's
kind of stupid then in high school a guy
told me that's goofball [__] you look
like a nerd so then for like four years
I switched to this yeah well let me do
it yeah dominant hand yeah or like this
but this feels weird my fingers are all
yeah you know yeah I like this but is
this nerdy yeah it's nerdy like if
someone you were like at the edge of
fighting someone what would be more
scary to see this
or this
okay I I go I know what's the right way
you go you better know now I feel stupid
doing this people this is not right yeah
because you it you're it's well that's
exactly right that's distracting yeah
you're taking away the power of this
yeah right right so this is ridiculous
so you what do you do okay so well if
I'm gonna fight yeah but if I'm gonna
fight everything goes to fighting games
yeah I know I'm not I'm not giving you
the finger
I'm just moving in
right all right dude yeah you're closing
the gap
yeah okay and then it's not gonna matter
because you're just gonna hear a loud
bang all right dude because what you're
gonna slip and fall and hit your head no
you're gonna take a nap oh wow how
amazing would that be bang in here yeah
no you're gonna I'm stupid I've never
said that I don't say anything I was
stupid I didn't say anything that makes
me weak Jordan Peterson you guys have a
minute oh no dude okay okay
a lot of people say go like this I don't
like that I put that [__] thing I
[__] dude I strap it I strap the
other fingers down boom that's fine what
I do is this though I think it's
something I think there's something
really powerful about yeah about just so
so you just look at the person you go
like that and they think that you're
gonna fight them you go like that like
you're gonna shake your fist wow Jude so
I'll just go like this I just go like
that uh-huh
okay
you'd be knocked out by now already and
then I go like would be knocked down I
don't know do you see how slow that was
yeah but they would be already [__]
knocking so be yelling at me hey hey
screw you man you're the worst I don't
like you dude what do you do what is
that man who do you think you are what
is it what do you do
I play the piano [__] and then there's a
story about me
dude without this finger this finger's
permanently disfigured yeah but I still
crush it all right at the end yeah
you're crying because I'm crushing it
you're mine I'm playing The Rock Nine
you're what rock man enough all right do
it I love piano man oh I love playing I
don't you never played piano I live for
classical piano my fingers bounce you
know the story no I don't know the story
balance my father my [__] father I
used to just I used to be forced to sit
at a piano but I wasn't given a stool I
had to hold a squat my legs would burn
and my fingers would dance across the
piano they really would yes and my papa
who was a fierce military man had a
cruel smell he smelled like gunmetal and
tobacco and leather and he would Lord
over me with a rattan cane and he would
bring it down on my boy back my naked
boy back again boy and I would say yes
Papa thank you for not giving up on me
Papa and he would place the piano in
front of the window for home and I would
watch the children of the neighborhood
play through my tears dude Brian what
you're the worst person
how many times you said you were gonna
break my finger yeah how how when's the
worst what's the last time you uh told
that story that's just it popped out
okay you're a lunatic you you you you
live in a fantasy world I don't know
what you're talking about
I just recalled my father being abusive
all right and he used to Lord over me
and I still have marks on my back from
his Rattan his return stop saying Rattan
dude learned Rattan today
learned written King today fine okay I'm
sorry that I got personal on this
podcast sorry let's let's bring it back
to stupid land
play in the next video next one
what's up guys I'll be seeing you in
Tulsa nice
um when I'm doing the horizontal Mambo
that sucks I'll be too quick to splurkin
yeah word up so how do I he wins slow
down so quick
yep yeah help me out okay okay also side
note house a [__] is it when you get
out of the shower and you're trying to
dry yourself off especially trying to
reach back and uh wash your back dry
your back off yep thanks guys it
actually is dude it'll be like this
you know it is when you got a back that
way film The Lord of the Rings on but
I'll tell you what dude this guy yeah uh
about the horizontal monitor dude quick
to splurt you win you win yep oh dude
because you know why why because you
know when people say life's about the
journey
nah no it's about to splurt no I don't
think so dude come on no I went when I
when I do if I do if I'm with my wife I
go Whoa man I go I want that one oh God
and then I roll over I Lop over and I
just go and I turn on [__] gross yeah
something with uh what's his name what's
that guy's name uh [__] God you've
lost a bit wait what's his name you know
what I say what I say you're welcome or
this is for you no or God Bless America
oh that's not good that's what I said I
go I go I win I go like that and I go oh
oh oh she said what I said I'm about to
win
um and then I [__] and I and I Lop over
dude and I'm not even dude I Lop over
and I go and and dude in my [__]
beard hair is all gross and Nappy and
[__] if you if you don't want to come
think about that just think about Chris
doing that play Chris talking about how
he nuts and you won't yeah dude or you
know how you stop coming too quickly
think about your mom no dude that's not
that's not cool Food Network
are you looking at the Guyton Alton
Brown
dude I go oh no I go oh no you know what
I do before I honestly before I if I'm
too quick oh no I said oh no I'm about
to be silly and then I
don't do that noise
and then I flop over and I go and then I
turn on something with Alton Brown so
disrespectful I won and then look over
the thing I won oh that's not attractive
and your tongue sticks out you're so
lazy you're too lazy to even keep your
tongue in your mouth I go just sorry I
was so silly
oh
you know okay I'm 56 man I can't do this
anymore really I can't I want to quit I
don't want to do this I don't want this
to be my life I want to be taken
seriously there are people who have been
presidents at my age dealing with stuff
and I'm doing this
foreign
do I have friends who are mathematicians
and like
sorry I was silly
I don't want to do this anymore like I
want to quit everything I wish I had the
money to just go away and like read
books I'd still call you I want to be an
adult I'd still call you and it would
still do these bits dude
sorry I was so silly uh you know but is
my tongue out again you know we have
kids and they're gonna look us up and go
what did your dad do my dad my dad you
know create him up with a new app or a
new way to do an operation what'd your
dad do
dude I [__] he'll go never mind
nah dude I sometimes people see me and
they go they go oh dude did you have sex
today and I say why your tongues out
yeah oh and there you go it's all brown
uh and you go coffee and muffins my son
didn't finish his muffins and I don't
brush or wipe I air dry my mouth and my
[__] oh god well what now oh now
that's too much that's too much that's
too much dude [__] man you're
you're unhealthy looking what dude yeah
so you know [__] I have a karate class
in two hours
I'll have time to stretch all right keep
going all right next one yeah
hey guys Okay so
[Music]
um you drive a lot and I happen to have
to drive during the worst possible time
to drive sucks um I know y'all live in
Los Angeles I've dealt with Southern
California traffic myself I live in
Sacramento now but I swear it is
atrocious and I just get so mad at
nothing so like how do you what do you
guys do to stay calm especially in your
in your traffic do y'all just hire
drivers or Brian do you have to like
listen usually I'm listening to Lifeline
as well do to chill out I have to like
make myself laugh but other than that
I'm literally able to learn a lot from
my interviews angry [__] and I don't
ever give out road rage but I just hate
it I hate driving now um
I never do I don't get mad at drugs dude
I have an I have to like [__]
sometimes I get angry bro I just gotta
breathe you do yeah over what
traffic little [__] bro you can't
control that oh dude oh
hey you just cured me man okay but I
mean oh I can't control it oh dude I
wish somebody just said that okay why
are you mad at that the fact there are
just too many cars it's not even about
yourself oh [__] dude like what like
[__] dude like
I don't want to talk about him no you
can tell me I'll help you
and I bet I can provide a solution
so what do you get mad about I'll have
to think about it okay so let me so can
I make yeah so the next time you get mad
call me okay I'll come over okay okay
it'll take so long and I'm gonna take
this part of my hand that part of my
hand and I'm gonna paint brush your
stupid Los Angeles face that's it don't
because you're not in New York and
you're not East Coast
I'll slap I'll slap it out of you so
then you have perspective and you go man
it could be so much worse
dude that it could be worse for anyone
man okay this is not not if you're on
fire if you were on fire that it can't
get worse so you have to be more careful
with how you talk all right well right
so assuming that I'm not fired nobody
ever says somebody who's on fire could
be worse because it can't right well all
I'm saying is that yeah but I'm what I'm
saying is you're not really probably
talking to somebody who's on fire
because they're already gonna admit okay
but you said it can always be worse and
I've said I said I corrected you okay
okay what if someone was on fire like oh
no I'm on fire I'm on fire and then
somebody literally came up to him and
said oh dude I have news for you your
father never loved you that's worse I
don't I got you dude oh no I'm on fire
and are you serious oh no and then they
die I I guess technically yeah
I don't I don't think you're right
though because I think when you're on
fire I don't think any of that is heard
and I don't think you're worried about
that I don't think you're even able to
hear somebody when you're on fire
so I think your points moved hey dude
now now I will say this if you're on
fire and then they go you think that's
bad and then they let your family on
fire that's probably when it gets worse
you know what's funny what
I was uh
I I noticed I had this like little scr
you see the scrape right there that
looks like it's uh gonna lead to
something just a little a little scrape
right yeah but that's how it starts but
you see it right okay A little red right
there yeah
I'm like I don't know what the hell it
is but it's it's like this and it's been
like that for a long time yeah it's a
wound that won't heal yeah so I go to
the uh I was actually at the doctor for
something else and I was like what is
this this won't get worse he's like I
don't know just keep tabs on it it's
like all right
Weeks Later months later I'm back at the
doctor for something else I asked you
know I said what is this and he's like
yeah it's there it's okay probably it's
just a red thing you figure it out
and I'm like okay uh but I'm kind of
worried about it because it's been so
long that it's been there
and so I really start to think about
like how what is it why does this why
why is this here because it's not there
for no reason right so I'm like all
right I'm trying to keep tags of what
I'm doing every day
keep it like this so I noticed the only
thing that I do
when I keep like this is the only thing
I do is when I go into my yep genes
right so I'm like okay well it's got to
be something there so I started really
paying attention when I go to my keys
like this and then I I noticed that when
I go for my keys or whatever it is when
I go for my wallet whatever it is that's
when I do feel something okay and I I'm
so like I think it's just one pair of
jeans so I take the jeans off I look at
the jeans there's nothing there
and then I put on other jeans and I keep
noticing it's happening with the other
jeans too so now I'm like is something
up with my hand the way it goes into my
jeans or whatever like that
every pair of jeans I wear I'm doing
like this so I I look at every pair of
jeans there's nothing there and then
it's nothing here I go I try medicine
nothing's really helping him I wear
jeans every day so I'm finally like dude
I'm losing my mind Calvin has a little
like um has a like a science kit and I'm
like maybe if I grab the magnifying
glass I'm gonna look at the genes in
that way because something's got to be
up with these jeans yeah so I grabbed
the mic the the the what do you call it
the magnifying glass and I look at these
jeans and and I'm I'm looking at
studying and I see this very very very
very very very very very very
extremely tiny diving board
and I'm like what and then I realize oh
it's cause my pockets
stay deep
right
I got I got diving but I got diving
boards on my jeans right above my
because my pockets Run Deep
you know
just the nuts too long a story to get to
that and I want my time back I have I
have to be on a plane tonight
I can't I'm busy man I can't I'm I want
an adult conversation
stupid
diving board yeah [__] dude
so all right yeah I have to carry my
money around my backpack or something
don't use cash
you know you wanna go next caller yeah
let's go to the next car man God Maddie
from says uh Chris you just recently
sent us a cameo right before I had my
son Doc and it was really awesome so
thank you for that thank you uh but
since having our son we've been drinking
a lot of coffee any other day my husband
decided to get the Chris special which
four shots of espresso over ice
uh is a little intense and he was
wigging out super hard and we were
wondering like how you got there has it
always been four shots you kill your
adrenals okay yeah you kill your
adrenals what has your caffeine Journey
looked like
um yeah anyways we love the podcast love
you guys see ya okay
yeah weekly adrenals yeah yeah that's
why I drink so much coffee who cares how
much coffee how many how many shots of
espresso do you have and you don't pay
attention to the taste either I've got
no idea how many shots I have but the
other day I had four shots and it wasn't
enough and I got a headache
I would I had to take Advil because I
was I was at home I was like I gotta go
to sleep now now you go now you sleep uh
do you sleep 11 or 12 hours how many
hours oh bro I I dude I've been [__]
struggling sleeping now oh yeah I know
that's because you get older and you're
just drinking all the coffee no no no no
no no I've always been drinking all the
coffee yeah but you get older you get
older and it [__] you up man so now I
wake up I'm eating before you go to bed
yeah yeah yeah I live the life of a king
okay but don't do that yeah whatever
when when what do you want to eat you
want to eat I'm hungry yeah I don't ever
think about it okay do you want to order
something I'm not hungry now but I will
be when the food gets here that's me she
can toss and turn I toss and turn dude I
got a [__] belly full of pasta just
watching Alton Brown just oh you wanna
let me win babe oh God
oh it's barely full of pasta he's got a
poo oh man all right bad posture huh
like a joke you know I have good posture
you have bad posture your your back is
made of of rope you're like a crustacean
nah hey dude I I have a good posture man
what the [__] there's something about me
huh you're a human let's go to the next
one what is it
this is Jack from Chicago so I was out
to dinner with some friends the other
night some of which I knew better than
others and you know I ate my full meal
I'm like Chris a hamburger is just a
snack to me
but then when the meal was over and we
were all just sitting there I noticed
that the girl sitting across from me had
not eaten all her food and so I was like
hey you mind if I finish off that
chicken and she was like ah you know
just kind of brushed me off said no and
so I was like okay I pulled back right
maybe she wants a box maybe she wants to
take it home
waiter comes clears the plate she
doesn't ask for a box okay so nobody
gets to eat that food and now I'm
sitting there like hey yeah well am I
the weirdo in a friendly situation
asking to eat someone else's food
or is that a little bit of out of line
let me know this one guys it's one of
those things that's not out of line but
what are you doing eat your food and
then order something else or like what
although that girl's weird because yeah
well actually like if you say you want
can I have your food I go yeah yeah yeah
you're not gonna eat it yeah go ahead
yeah but but why is this guy or I go
like this there you go
there you go
you feed him that guy yeah she should
have done that
but what did he do with it
cut a small piece
yeah dude these peanuts
um
that's a dick barf yeah that was awesome
yeah ah
all right dude so feeding that thing
peanut it's weird to be like it's weird
to be like hey can I have your food to
somebody yeah
it's that's also weird like you're gonna
you're gonna eat that you're gonna eat
that yeah like she probably was like
maybe yeah right like she was like I
don't know yet yeah maybe but then and
they came and she was probably like no
you can take it what if that's the guy
that's just always like you're gonna do
like he was like oh that's not inviting
she might have been the kind of girl
that said thinks that's bad manners and
so she went right I was thinking about
dating him but you know what now you did
that nah right have you ever been on a
date with a girl she does one thing and
you go and I can't do it yeah like what
what was your thing manners one time uh
she just threw all up over the table and
goes like this
let's get out of here and I go and I
can't why does she talk that way
um she was 95.
yeah that's an old lady huh
but she had work done so no I I I uh
yeah one time there was one time where
uh actually one time where I was with a
um
a woman that I was seeing kind of and
she and we were eating at Bossa Nova you
know the place in uh on Sunset anyway
but it's good we're eating from the
Laugh Factory right no no not even close
so um so it's not because there so I'm
just guessing so um you might as well
not say anything instead of that so um I
was with her and she was eating and I
was eating with her
I'm like maybe I like this girl I don't
know if she's cool she's hot and then
she was uh she was eating and then she's
just like going like this like as she's
eating
and she goes and she literally says to
me I don't know I just stopped dancing
when I eat
and I go like this in my head if she
only knew I thought what am I doing yeah
and I didn't hang out with her again
yeah yeah don't be that my friend was on
a date with a girl who didn't who who he
she was she talked fast yeah she was
aggressive she was pretty and
um
she ate her whole meal
without taking her gum out of her mouth
oh come on I'm dead serious what bro she
ate her whole meal that's disgusting
without taking her gum out of her mouth
and he kind of went I think she might be
a little crazy but he couldn't tell yeah
you can talk to that and then
um and then she ran for president
out of her van she got a van and it
didn't she didn't get elected did she at
least make the uh top eight or whatever
you couldn't even do that apparently no
what do they call it but she had a loud
speaker and he saw her and like
campaigning for president vote for me
and he went well that was see that's I
that was good that I didn't want a
second date with that person right yeah
I guess I wish she was our president
honestly huh I think right now she would
[__] be killing it over Biden yeah
probably I don't know he's old but he's
very old yeah
um next uh
Chris disgusting got a question for you
guys is that part of the necklace that
was on a work trip recently and he had
like a hour-long flight that he was
about to go on okay and he was hungry so
he got uh a tuna fish sandwich in the
terminal
um but he didn't eat it
in the terminal so he waited until he
got onto the airplane no and uh
I think that's wrong yeah it is I think
you should eat your sandwich now yeah
100 thanks for the example when you get
it that's the problem and then I just
feel like that's wrong to
one have a tuna fish sandwich that you
buy at a terminal and two to wait until
you're on the airplane and he had time
to eat it before but uh
I think it's wrong to wait because one
tuna fish is stinky and two that's just
gross so well it's just stinky
it's the stinky thing that's bad yeah
yeah you don't do eggs tuna yeah Chinese
food there was somebody who brought out
[__] Chinese food once yep uh even
but honestly even like anything dude
yeah if it's if it's too smell then no
if too much of a smell then no like
peanut butter jelly sandwich like a
jerky can smell like yeah yeah yeah but
if it's hot food or tuna or eggs yeah
bro dude that's why for me it's I always
bring some salted game meat okay I've
killed myself and if I've earned it some
sliced yams if I've earned all right so
this is like if you're going to for me
to earn him for me to earn a starch
yeah is I mean this is becoming
something that it's not well I punish
myself right so right so if if my body
is screaming for mercy and I go we're
gonna we're gonna do a couple more sets
we're gonna run a couple more Hills okay
right when I get to the wall I climb the
wall okay right right I climb the wall
okay most people go like a guy like who
goes there's a wall
I can't okay I climbed the wall all
right right okay
then I'll let myself eat some yams
take it easy this guy's talking about a
tuna fish sandwich the salt doesn't
smell
keep it natural keep it natural okay
right yeah so when I do this you're fine
when I do that yeah
we're about to go to battle and the next
We're Not Gonna See Is I'm gonna blink
and it's gonna be that bang again all
right listen dude the guy's talking
about I bring smelly food on an airplane
and you're talking about [__] running
hills
you're bored with that yeah
I think that you should not bring smelly
food on the airplane period especially
if it's an hour-long flight you're a
piece of [__] eat it before or after
right right what do you snack on on the
plane nuts
um I eat maybe I'll have like some maybe
like chocolates I might eat uh the
person's next to me that might snack on
their hair that's gonna yeah
yeah just don't I don't even like it
it's disgusting for me but it [__] with
him and it's like I'm so Alpha when I do
it what is he he just scared you they
normally don't say something sometimes
they'll be like what are you doing and
I'll be like how can you stop me yeah
I'll say go ahead and try and stop me
yeah and then they just go yeah and it's
not worth it because usually like you
know an older lady or something
I don't care okay yeah good dude I was
on a plane the other day yeah and uh I
told this on my congratulations podcast
but some [__] this alarm went off
this lady went to go to the bathroom to
the alarm went off yeah and uh and her
alarm went off in the seat and she
wasn't there and I was like that
nobody's touching it it was three
minutes the lady next to me goes like
this looks at me I'm on my phone I'm
like this next week she goes like this
is that your phone and I was like do you
know I couldn't even tell you how angry
I got what
I said what my phone I would turn it off
dude that that you asked me what makes
me angry that kind of [__] makes me
angry but you should have gone like this
this is what makes me angry what the
story that you're telling because I want
to go back and I want to go back and I
want to go hey you go like that to her
phone but you didn't want to touch her
phone yeah yeah because I don't want to
go to people's property I don't like to
touch people that's worth it watch this
I know I know and it would have been
fine if mine was going off and someone
did that but like you know get it
together when she came back she go oh
sorry yeah yeah she was like oh my God
I'm so sorry she was cool about it yeah
it was so I even know phones and then
you you put her her hair back in your
mouth yeah she's sitting in front of me
so I just I waited for her to recline
and then I go like this actually when
people recline yeah I just get I bring
shampoo and I just
I do their hair oh yeah you know what I
did there was a woman in front of me and
she was talking to her friend and they
were freezing she was freezing I always
bring stuff but she was freezing she had
like shorts and like and I I and it was
a cold flight it was like three hours
yeah and um and after I was done you
know kind of taking pictures and stuff
yeah Okay I uh I uh I just couldn't take
it anymore and I took out my fleece and
I gave it to her oh and she goes she
goes like this she goes
thanks okay that's cheers thanks you're
kidding me puts it on okay and now it's
done she goes
oh after it she goes thanks and hands it
back but kind of like a thanks I was
like
oh you got to be kidding me yeah like
hey say more say more yeah say more that
I saved you because I know it was
freezing like say more she goes do you
have blankets no nothing and then she
goes back to talking to her friend I was
like and her friend felt better friend
goes thank you
dude what's up with pieces of [__] oh
God you open a door to somebody they
walk in they don't say [__] my friend
found somebody's wallet the woman goes
yeah I can't pick it up then
um no yeah she goes yeah all right maybe
can you meet me oh no that's not gonna
work for me yes he was like unbelievable
I have your [__] wallet she's like no
that won't work for me um let me think
when I can pick it up yeah can you do it
like how about like how's Tuesday he was
like are you out of here
come get it
that's crazy you don't come now I made
money I made money yeah wow that's
insane yeah awful all right well uh
that's it that's the last one thanks for
listening
um I got so many places going on sale uh
they're all on sale now go to Hamilton
go to uh Knoxville and [__] Ohio and
all sorts of places in Florida I got
Montreal Edmonton Nashville Charlotte
Colorado Springs go peruse crystalia.com
new dates all live now
um and uh you want to plug anything or
what look guys I did my special man
tears just dropped check out his
specialist go watch [__] hilarious
hilarious yeah and uh and I'll be at uh
in Portland uh go to briancallen.com I
got May I'm busy in May I got uh the
vasani theater May 4th five and six I
got a bunch of stuff the next week and
the next week and the next week and I
think I'm doing something every weekend
I met you know what I'm saying bro yeah
man all right all right dude
hey I brought I pumped this thing up all
right it's fine dude it's gonna do well
because people like us together
all right tune in next time that'll be
better and we'll have the same program
that we usually do sorry about this
[__] bump in the road but thanks for
coming dude honestly thank you you're
welcome buddy you're one of your last
podcasts right we get up there so uh if
you have a question go to watch
lifeline.com to get the new merch
lifelinemerch.com Brian did you pass it
Brian Brian runs
okay anyway uh we appreciate you and
like And subscribe and leave a comment
pump the algorithm and also who's better
me or Brian me hey come on hey guys
thank you that's how it's done
[Music]